boy how movie landscape is changing
people oh my god
you soon we're gonna be in control we
might be getting an ear cut for Suicide
Squad it's pretty amazing to see what's
happening in the landscape right now
like this is a major win for what's
going on with this Snider cut I'm Greg
by the way that's John I know where the
rejects what's up and this is this news
came out like a day or two ago so in
movie news world this is old-ass News
but I did want to talk about it it's
certainly intriguing yeah with the
Snyder cut coming out officially I think
that's a beautiful thing because you
know that phrase we always hear
filmmakers say especially with
properties that are franchise base like
this list wouldn't be possible without
the fans is wouldn't ossible up the fans
Snyder cut is the like the purest of
accessible at all someone tweeted AT&T
who are oh I believe are the main ones
responsible for helping to fund the HBO
max release of the Snyder cuz they're
working in coordination whether they're
part of HBO max that I believe so this
user M Meccano said complete the gift
and release the Erica please please
PLEASE an AT&T said one thing at a time
honestly to respond to that in that way
means they're at least trying to get
there or considering it right yeah I
mean if this did piece of the dam broke
with the Snyder cut you can only imagine
that this was gonna carry and David Ayer
said standing by AT&T responded to David
Ayer's tweet with an enchantress photo
anything is possible all it takes is a
little bit of magic this is funny to me
because Suicide Squad came out when that
came out David I a or stood by saying
that is his director's cut the
theatrical version we got was a
director's cut people didn't notice and
like we all remember the behind the
scenes of like after BBS and the
response that happened with that of how
the studio was really going in and and
tampering with what David Haye
originally wanted to do and I don't
think most of us actually believed that
that was the original vision
David Ayer had in mind he was just
playing ball and not trying to rock the
boat exactly I think I think most of us
were on that train there's an article I
found I was looking for it I found
online it was great one from Screen Rant
from many years ago that was basically
going through all the moments in the
Suicide Squad trailer that are not in
the movie what's funny about getting an
ear cut is that eventually we already
got another cut which is the extended
edition of Suicide Squad right that's
not exactly an A or cut it's just a few
more scenes on top of they don't like
remix it in any way as like any unrated
cut that comes out you know yeah they
cram a couple things they deleted from
what almost came out it's like just 10
to 15 minutes more and honestly like the
first time I saw Suicide Squad we
watched it together
I remember our review of who's a lot of
fun you know if you watch our original
review I thought it was a lot of fun
like it's messy when we watched the
extended edition and I felt bad cuz
Warner Brothers sent us a copy of that
yeah yeah sure I know where the few
people actually gave it a decent review
they're gonna watch the extended edition
on that rewatch had a completely
different experience oh no no I don't
like this actually with the extra
footage it makes me like Jared Leto's
Joker even less but a few months ago
David Ayer I mean I don't know exactly a
few months ago but he did put out
something here because there's in that
article from Screen Rant they didn't
notice that in the big beam from
enchantress that the designs of the the
you know those like putty henchmen that
are in Suicide Squad are completely
different in the Suicide Squad trailer
and then David Ayer put out a photo a
while ago that said this is a maka
para demon head that was 3d printed I
shot the image of my Nikon apparently
what the original plan was to do put the
parademons in there possibly Steppenwolf
would appear then they would tie in
closer to you know Justice Lee yeah
right that was the original plan
apparently David Ayer did say that there
are hours of footage of Jared Leto as
Joker collecting dust somewhere and he
originally planned he's that's where you
have to put it on the hard drive like
Zack Snyder did you have much larger
plan in the DC EU he also teased a
larger
or fulfilling role for Harley Quinn and
she didn't find she's the only one who's
really getting clockwork Suicide Squad
and a stronger connection to Justice
League essentially I don't know all the
details of what exactly was in the Erica
cuz even in that Screen Rant article I
found it's it's mainly like little
moments like a big thing that people
were kind of hoping to see was this
image right here you got Jared Leto
Joker he's got like a grenade in hand
yeah and his face looks all burnt up
yeah and so that moments not in the
movie that looks like a really cool
moment and I'd like to see it yeah I
don't think they will get any word on
this until Snyder comes out and they see
how it performs yeah if it makes its
money back because they're throwing down
about twenty to thirty million for it
right now right now reportedly they
throw in about twenty or thirty million
are people gonna sign up for it and what
is the reception going to be to it
they're gonna need to have both do well
not just money but also critical
reception I know some people might argue
with me on that saying no it just needs
to make money maybe I think for this
case they're gonna need fans to like it
yeah yeah especially because they are in
a weird position now where they are
acknowledging the vision that they made
us a sharp left turn from and have
committed to following okay so now that
we have a kind of semi established new
iteration of the DC EU there's also
going to be I think some rectification
of that confusion for people who aren't
as in the know about this kind of thing
you know who aren't following these
stories along so much and we don't know
that the details of what all needs to be
done like Snyder is saying for his for
his version of Justice League they'll
need to do some additional reshoots not
just VFX touch-ups but actually get some
of the cast back involved to you know do
some actual shooting of it now I don't
know if the air cut needs that because
it sounds like there's just a lot of
footage on the cutting room floor yeah
it seems like the kind of project where
they probably had and the footage of a
different movie and then went back and
reshot even more to change it so yeah it
might be less of an undertaking yeah so
like apparently one thing that for sure
David Ayer has commented on is that it
is more character rich there's more
breathing room
yada yada yada and for as much as his
cram and
to our film or I think it's like a
little over two hours I don't remember
right now felt like three yeah as much
as crammed in there yeah one would that
breathes better it would be the biggest
benefit to this now why I think
reception of a positive response first
snider cut beyond it just making money
but why the reception is important is
because if fans don't like it I just
don't see a version or HBO max would be
inclined then to go well now let's do
the air cut because the DC EU was making
a lot was making a lot of money than
financial decline was happening who it
yeah you know what and and it would be a
repeat of the situation that they
hopefully learned from in the sense that
you know you have Batman V Superman
which felt like an unsinkable ship at
the time and then you know that did well
Suicide Squad did well with the box
office but with those two poor returns
on word-of-mouth you know you see
Justice League's yeah sharp dip and I
feel like yeah you're absolutely right
if people don't care that much for the
Snyder cut they're gonna be aware I
think of that drop in the word of mouth
and yeah the meme that it like there's a
lot of eyes on that movie because it has
to be good that's to be at this point
yeah exactly I would not buy into the
argument of a lot of people didn't tune
in for Justice Li because of the behind
the scenes situation that occurred
because to this day there's a lot of
people around the world who really don't
know what what this is about
I've seen on not just our video comments
but on other people's going wait what
what is this Snider cut thing exactly
why why is this a big deal there are
people who still don't really grasp it
most people are not in tune so much
necessarily with like the movie world
nitty gritty behind the scenes and blah
blah blah so a lot of people have no
don't really know what it is and the
Suicide Squad I think would have an even
bigger hurdle of trying to push that the
calling for an A or cut is nowhere near
as prevalent my petition feel free to
sign I don't really hear I like the air
cut sounded like a joke to me at first
it sounds like a plausible thing it
sounds like a real thing that I'm sure
David Ayer would love to do but it
didn't really seem like it's ever had as
much of a passion behind it as the
Snyder cut for Justice League obviously
I think everyone could agree on that
just from a filmmaker standpoint it's
actually the one I'd be
more interested because you know a that
movie seems like with Justice League we
at least know that a different
filmmakers stamp got put on it we know
roughly what Zack Snyder's stamp had
been up to that point but David a our
life since the beginning of that whole
process I was a good choice for this and
then it went so left of that you know
that I would yeah I'd love to see his
actual film version because I think he's
a filmmaker still well-suited to that
project there's always passion behind it
because like Zack Snyder had a one too
and didn't get it do with the proper
part through to his his film series that
he was working on this was just the
first one yeah you know yeah there's
more like David Ayer just didn't get to
make his proper first impression and on
top of that too I didn't really care for
Jared Leto's Joker the first time I
watch it I didn't hate it but when I saw
him in the extended version I really
didn't like him like they had this full
on additional scene between him and
Harley on like on the highway or on the
road something like that and he just got
on my nerves in that scene I don't hear
as many people championing to like we
need more footage of chair Leto to prove
he's he actually did a good job now
maybe that's the case maybe with more
footage and a different variety of
scenes though you know you put them in a
certain order blah blah blah it might
actually be better and I'd actually be
good yeah in a movie that has more room
to move and breathe and be about
characters instead of about which pop
song you can throw in yeah so I would be
interested in seeing this I never
actually saw the actual petition going
around I bet there is a thanks man
for all your support you you email me
John I'm gonna ignore you alright just
ask me I work in the same office all day
I'll text Olivia I would be interested
in seeing this I mean like why the hell
not the thing is though we will not hear
a peep about this actually going into
production until the Snider cut does
come out and depending on how that is
received financial critically audience
whatever then we like if that's good I
can I think there's like like an 80%
chance this will come out think that it
does create this weird return investment
where they're kind of making two movies
out of one set of shoot footage so even
though they would have to dump some
extra money into Suicide Squad and
know if it'll be the tune that they're
doing for justice yeah but I don't know
it seems like there is a potential for
them in a way that you know making a
whole new movie would kind of cost more
for ya and I'm not sure exactly what
they're considering in terms of the fact
that if they would do this and then
James Gunn's
there's a lot of anticipation for his
version of the Suicide Squad yeah
there's a lot of anticipation for that a
lot of people have a lot of faith that
that will actually be pretty damn good
considering James Gunn's track record
and then considering how DC has been in
my opinion I think DC has been doing
great at least Jenkins cut like it's
interesting to try to go back and
course-correct some of these things or
make some of these better because
honestly like after justice Lee we got
Shazam Joker Aquaman and we like birds
of prey might be my favorite of all I
feel like DC's been doing really good
lately and yeah just have to wait and
see but guys do you care about this one
do you want an A or cut the idea that
AT&T is not shutting this down at all
and it's pretty much saying let's just
wait and we're gonna revisit this yeah
maybe this will become the new let's
make a sequel just to part 1 yeah that
movie we screwed up by making a bunch
financial decision probably all right
guys we'll leave your thoughts down
below if you guys like this video make
sure to subscribe please hit that like
button if you enjoyed it too and also
make sure to click that notification
probably the notify would never got a
YouTube video up last but not least
let's do up lb and Lance door so this is
a fan fiction patient of the day shadow
of what if these two met each other
written by John get ready so gonna love
it have no idea what I'm stepping in
right now strange
stream-of-consciousness who do you wanna
play I'll play el alright I'll be Lance
door reprising my role of Landstar
reprise in my role of lb just makes
sense
cinematic patreon crossover exterior
Canada afternoon sexy firefighter Lance
door stands in front of a burning Tim
Hortons fire hose in hand soon after
intrepid journalist
lb shows up next to him with her trusty
notepad looks like things are heating up
around here and not because of your
perfect firefighters physique ah thanks
hey it happens sometimes when I get too
close to flammable objects figure you
got to finish what you start so here I
am that's hairy cavity QED hands or
Canadians are known for being kind it's
true although to be honest the way
people stereotype us sometimes just
really makes me just want to understand
where they're coming from a knowledge
the parts that are accurate also
acknowledging their shortsightedness and
ignorance thus allowing yourself to
release it that's exactly what I was
gonna say you're so cool lands dork I'm
almost sad that you have such a perfect
beautiful family oh that's alright I
think you're pretty cool as well lb now
do you think you could doctor up that
article you're writing and make it look
like I didn't just set this place ablaze
with my boyish charm and devilish good
looks Lance are you asking me to
fabricate a piece of pipe news well when
you put it that way
I guess we ought to make this thing a
full confession the problem has gotten
so out of hand that I can't continue
using firehouse resources like this oh
well hey oh now maybe there's a way we
can make this work in both of our favors
now that sounds Lance tastic lb what is
your ingenious plan smash - front page
of the Arkansas Hollywood Reporter
showing Lance has just been cast as the
Human Torch in Marvel's upcoming
Fantastic Four reboot
wow thanks lb I know this isn't exactly
the sort of journalism you've
specialized in throughout your life but
then again I'm not an actor yeah the two
laugh is John Krasinski enters the room
telling Lance to get his ass back on set
and Hale to start writing the sequel I'm
a screenwriter yet - laughs again as
Lance's daughter is cast as Sue Storm
you really know how to honor them DNA
you know it's all from the heart